more likely to rip their pants on the
course like tom brady see i got
different wardrobe i got a fat wardrobe
i got a skinny wardrobe so i'm probably
gonna have my fat wardrobe so my pants
will not be bursting hi this is peyton
manning i'm stephen curry
i'm charles barkley i'm phil mickelson
and this is matchmaking
[Music]
who has been practicing more for this
event i'm gonna go with
sir charles that'd be me i'm just trying
not to embarrass myself america
i've been hitting balls five or six
hours a day i played every day
it doesn't mean it's helping but i'm
gonna go with my man more likely to
bogey a whole it's gotta be my playing
partner
peyton manning i'm playing really well
right now right here that's not a hard
question
sorry peyton more likely to rip their
pants on the course like tom brady
i i'm actually gonna go with me i tend
to squat down a little bit and charles
just buys bigger pants
that'll be phil mickelson see i got
different wardrobe i got a fat wardrobe
i got a skinny wardrobe so i'm probably
gonna have my fat wardrobe so my pants
will not be bursting
would i make a better quarterback or
payton a better point guard i gotta give
me the nod on being a better quarterback
you know the vertical elite left me just
a long time ago so i'm gonna go with
steph at quarterback
i feel like my skills will translate
really well i'm a pretty good passer on
the court
use his quick release right get the ball
out of his hands
i don't want him taking a lot of hits
back there from j.j watt
but uh i think he can get it out of his
hands bigger trash
talker on the golf course oh phil
mickelson
easily sad to say but it's true
see i'm not good enough to talk trash
phil's a great great player and he can
talk trash with the best of them
trash talker stuff right here i don't
know if he does it but
if he does any of it that's more than
what this guy does
that's why i picked peyton i saw i saw
how he went at tom and how he went at
tiger and phil
who's shot's gonna end up in the sand
trap first but don't worry peyton i'll
rake the bunker for you
it's all good i'm going to say me right
there this guy i could easily hit in the
bunker but my guy's got serious touch
around the green so won't be a problem
getting up and down
better acting charles and space jam are
me and entourage
charles and space jam i'm an awful actor
clearly you have watched space jam
charles barkley who would make a better
head coach
i'll go with steph i'll probably give it
to peyton i'm the head coach of my
son's flag football team right now we're
one and three it's about
the extent of my coaching career wait
peyton you said you're one and three as
a coach
no i'm gonna switch my answer but we we
can't accept that record
it's gotta be me better nickname lefty
or sir charles sir charles
oh sir charles what kind of nickname is
that just cause you're left-handed
people call you lefty i said y'all's got
a lot
more zing to it better signature move
well this is a run away i'm going with
steph again steph's
shimmy the shimmy is iconic right it's
it's got to be me
not 100 sure what the manning face is
what's worse charles's swing or my
dancing
you know they used to say white men
can't jump but fearless proof white men
can't dance
my moves are tight
more clutch with the game on the line
both of us
i'm going with both of us right i want
both of us on our on our team
that's the best answer we're both a
clutch you know how to get it done
with a big shot with a big touchdown
drive to lead or certainly a three-point
shot to win it so
i want both of us on our team who's
taking down more turkey at thanksgiving
my man sir charles oh that's tablet
charles barkley
i'm gonna die though america i'm coming
back strong
in 2025.